cameron is in new york city hey tamron
welcome to the ramsey show
thank you so much for having me how are
you doing today
better than i deserve how can we help
i am calling i recently i have a
question
that relates to college and when um
it is okay or sensible to
derail the plan and borrow for college
my husband and i we actually didn't even
discover
your system until during the pandemic
and we've paid down a lot of debt we've
sold a rental property
set up our emergency fund wonderful we
made a lot of progress in one year
well selling the selling the rental
property gave us a
large sum and we're blessed to have
terrific careers
but my oldest son is a senior in high
school this year
and last year he expressed an interest
that his dream school was
a prestigious private university that's
around here i graduated law school from
there myself
so um tugged at my heart and i was
supportive of him that if he did
everything that was necessary
and got the grades and kept everything
up as long as he
could get scholarships and aid and the
out-of-pocket expenses
for us was less than 25 000 a year that
we could afford to pay
cash through the school's payment plan
and that
he could go there um my sophomore
however um he had some trouble
um when he started high school last year
and he was getting into trouble and he
was making poor decisions
and then when they closed the schools
down
he kind of continued to go
down a scary path from our perspective
and he asked us if he could go away to a
boarding school to a military school
that's uh not too far from where we live
and
seeing that that was best for him we
immediately in december
agreed and enrolled him and sent him but
i'm now paying
2500 a month for him to go to school
and our budget only has
after all of the um bills and essentials
um like food and you know clothing
allows and haircuts like really the full
budget
only has about four thousand dollars to
spare in it
what's your household in i don't know um
right now we're at about 2 40
and i will be wrapping up my clerkship
my post law school clerkship
so i would expect that next year
it'll be closer to 300 if not over 300.
which will give you the money to send
the other one
yeah and that's why i was there's not a
plan where i did right we've been going
back and forth
to answer your earlier question there's
not a plan where i put you into student
loans
okay there's two options here one is we
figure this out or junior picks a
different school
okay and his future is not ruined based
on that
and pause listen pause is doesn't mean
never
doesn't mean stop it he could do his
first year somewhere else in
three years three through four yeah uh
or two through four
at the at the uh dream prestige school
again if he lines up all the
scholarships
and it's 25 000 out of pocket with no
student loans
he can also work towards this you know i
mean he understands what's going on in
the family and assuming you guys are
there's some harmony there and he's as
healthy as an 18 17 8 year old can be
about his brother's situation
he can work and kind of help out you
know with this process as well and say
hey here's where i think this is a
family meeting i think you sit him down
he said he said
he knows what's going on and just say
hey here's where we are
this is reality student loans is not an
option we're not going to do that
okay that's what dad and i have been
doing you've seen us getting out of debt
bring him in the bigger picture and say
hey life happens sometimes
this is a you know it's not fair it's
right it's sad and you didn't do
anything wrong
uh and yet it's affecting you but still
it is affecting you and so here's what
we're gonna do
uh let's pretend that you're you lost
your job
and you you couldn't send him to that
school you'd have the same conversation
and it wouldn't be his fault
you would have lost your job and he
would have to deal with that kids
kids can deal with this so hold on we're
going to send you a copy of anthony's
book debt-free degree i want you all to
read that as a family
and i want you to commit to working some
kind of a cash flow game plan
to some school that you pay cash for